[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Irit is a wellness
consultant, engineer, a mother,
and a wife.
During her 15 years of
meditation experience,
she had peaceful moments
that gave her time
to hear her thoughts
and self-talk.
She then realized the power that
her own thoughts had on her.
This helped her
develop a unique tool
based on research
that can help others
develop a positive mindset and
utilize their full potential.
Today, this took, which
is called ThinkUp,
has become the most popular app
for motivation ad affirmations
in the app store.
IRIT WALD: Hi, everyone.
I'm Irit Wald and
I would like to--
before I will talk about
myself and everything--
I would like to start
with something funny.
A very wealthy man invites all
the people in the neighborhood
to come to his wealthy party.
And inside his house, that was
a pool full with alligators
and sharks.
And he said, the one that
will swim across the pool
will get whatever he wants.
So there was a huge silence,
and then he heard one splash,
and someone started to swim,
swim, swim across the pool.
Get out of the pool,
tried to calm his breath.
So he arrived to
this man and he said,
young man, you're
the bravest man
I have ever seen
in my entire life.
What do you want in return?
So the young man said,
I want only one thing.
I would like to know who is
the guy that throw me in?
So with life, sometimes
things happen.
And in life, sometimes we get
inside pools full of alligators
and sharks and this
pool is dangerous for us
and there is a lot of
challenges and a lot
of obstacles in our life.
And it happens.
I don't even say for one minute
that life just happened to us.
I think we have
control over our life.
Yet sometimes
things happen to us.
So the main of this talk is to
help you overcome difficulties
in a way that will
help you get better
results in any situation.
And the most important thing is
how we overcome the challenges.
It's very nice to
overcome a challenge
and to be so tired
and so powerless.
But it's not the main
business of life.
All we need to do is to
develop the right mindset
and to know what and how we
can practice on a daily basis.
What can we do in
order to overcome
life, winners, successful, and
with a lot of happy moments?
One more story before we start.
One evening, an elderly
chief talking to his grandson
about a battle between two
wolves inside our head.
So he said, son, inside
every head of every person,
there are two wolves.
One of them is evil, is
angry, is hate, is fear.
It's low self-esteem.
The other one is love, is
compassion, is empathy,
is giving.
So the grandson just stop
and say, hey, hey, hey,
which wolf wins?
So the grandfather
just smile and said,
the one that you feed.
So all we need to understand
is how to feed the right one.
What to do in our life
and how to practice
our mind, our body, everything.
How to practice
our self in order
to feed the right wolf, to
overcome every challenge
in the way that
will encourage us,
uplift us, and make
us a better person,
a better version of ourself.
OK.
So let's stop all the story and
talk a little bit about you.
Everyone of you got this
near him, beside him.
And I'd like you to write
in the upper-right corner,
just in the upper-right corner.
I would like to diagnose you.
Not me, you diagnose yourself.
So if you need to--
if I ask you, how many positive
versus negative thoughts
you have a day, if you
need to evaluate yourself,
just on thought,
just throw a number.
What is the first
number that you think?
50/50 positive/negative?
60 positive, 40 negative?
Maybe 40 positive, 60 negative?
What do you think?
How do you think positive versus
negative emotion, thoughts
you have a day?
Just throw a number.
What do you think?
Because it's in your head.
You are the only one
that knows the answer.
No one but you knows it.
Did you write?
OK.
So after you write it and it's
written down on the paper,
I would like to know,
how much is 60/40?
60 positive, 40 negative?
How much is 60/40?
How much is 50/50?
No one 50/50?
OK.
60 negative, 40 positive.
How much is more negative?
Hi.
More negative.
OK.
So the funny thing--
it's not really funny,
but the funny thing
is 77% of the thoughts
of average person head
is negative.
77% of our thoughts
are negative,
meaning that we never reach
our full potential, never,
with 77%.
Never.
It means that-- for the
people that see us--
it means that if we don't
practice on a daily basis
and rewire our brain
day after day after day,
we just keep being
our mediocrity.
I'm not saying that you
are just in the middle.
I just said that you can be
much better, much better.
OK.
Let's continue.
There's five levels
of self-talk and I
would ask you to diagnose
yourself, so listen carefully.
Self-talk is the way
that we talked ourself
on a daily basis, what
we say to ourself.
This is self-talk.
So there are five levels.
I would like to know,
what level are you in?
The first one is
I'm not good enough.
I can't do it.
It's too hard.
I'm not capable enough.
This is the first one.
The second one, I
shouldn't do it.
Shouldn't do it and
it was a bad decision.
This is the second one.
The third one is I'm never
going to smoke again, eat sugar
again, I'm going to
exercise every day
or I'm never going to
procrastinate again.
This is the third level.
This is important.
The fourth one is just positive.
I'm grateful, thankful,
my life is good.
I'm happy with who I am.
I'm happy with what
happened in my life.
This is the fourth one.
And the fifth one, we are
all one consciousness.
Now think about, which
level are you in?
Write it down.
You have-- hey, you have this.
You have-- write down.
Which level are you in?
Because when you know what
happens inside your head,
you can start to work with it.
Otherwise, it just flows in
the space and you don't--
you didn't arrive
here just to know.
You arrived here
to do something.
So which level are you?
Did you write it down?
OK.
So sadly, most of
us are in level 1.
Most of us, all the
time just beat ourself.
We never remember
what our success
is because after we pass the
success, we move forward.
We don't remember.
And our success is the
basic of who we are.
This is the basic
of our character.
The basic of our character.
It means that the first one
is just Negative it only
destroys us.
Nothing good can happen
with this first level.
Nothing good.
The second one is
better, but I would
like to explain a bit
what's better with it.
I shouldn't do it means that
you focus your mind on the thing
that you don't don't want to do.
But you don't tell your
brain what he should do.
So your brain has
a lot of options,
yet you don't focus
in on the right thing.
Therefore, you never
reach the place
you want to reach because you
don't tell your brain what
you want.
The third one, I'm never
going to smoke again.
Here, you start to have
responsibility on your life.
You understand what you want.
You understand what
you don't want.
And if you understand
what you want and you
run in the right direction,
you decide, you visualize.
You have a plan.
You move one step forward,
you move other step forward.
You never give up.
You win everything.
This is the way
dreams come true.
This is the way to succeed in
anything that you want in life.
This is the way.
Sure thing.
Never give up, it will
arrive in the end.
But when you understand that
you don't need to do something,
again, you train
your brain or you
focus of brain on
the wrong direction.
So you just lose energy.
The first one is positive.
You understand that you
have wins, you have losses.
In those losses,
you learn things
that you need to do
in order to become
a better version of yourself.
And it really doesn't
matter what you achieve.
It matter what you became.
And if you put this
information in your head
that winning or losing,
it really doesn't matter.
It matter what you learned.
And the fifth one is just
byproduct of the fourth one,
so we will continue.
So now basically, you
have your measure.
You know how much
percent that you
have positive versus negative.
You know what is your
self-talk, what is
the self-talk inside your head.
Now you can work with it.
You understand what you do in
order to move one step forward.
Now I can tell you one thing.
That if you practice 10
minutes a day, when you sleep--
you don't even
need to be awake--
if you practice
10 minutes a day,
you can upgrade
your thought in 40%.
I mean you can uplift
yourself or have a better
performance in 40% by 10 minutes
a day when you go to sleep.
So close your eyes for a minute.
I know that it's not easy, but
close your eyes for a minute.
Don't go to sleep.
And imagine the most
successful person on earth.
Imagine.
It can be someone
from movies or it
can be someone from
your family or it
can be just imaginary
guy, girl, whatever.
Think a minute.
How do you define success?
What is success in your eyes?
In order to be very
specific, to bring
your thoughts and your brain
to a certain direction,
you need to know what you want.
So how do you define success?
Why does he or she
become so successful?
Why?
What is the reason?
Think about it.
And what kind of skill
does he or she have?
Now please open your
eyes and tell me
how do you define success?
What is success?
What is success in your eyes?
What it means to be successful?
What is?
For example.
AUDIENCE: Rich.
IRIT WALD: Money.
Let's call it financial freedom.
Financial freedom.
This is nice.
OK.
What more is to be successful?
What do you-- yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IRIT WALD: OK.
What more?
AUDIENCE: Being impactful.
Having an effect on the world.
IRIT WALD: To influence others.
Yeah, it's easier word for me.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: To live
with a purpose.
IRIT WALD: To live
Anyone else?
Maybe to have a
balance in your life
that you'll be very
successful and very
good family member, very
good person, to help society.
Maybe, maybe.
This is mine, but
doesn't say anything.
So we understand,
most of us understand
that to train our body,
to eat healthy food,
to exercise, to drink water,
is very important for the body.
But what about
detoxing the mind?
It's very nice to
eat healthy food,
yet it's very
important to practice
our mind on a daily basis.
Because without it, you can't
reach your full potential.
And if you are
here, Googlers, you
want to work at
your full potential
because you are in the
best company ever, right?
So to train your body, to
exercise, to drink water,
and to eat good food, to eat
healthy food, it's not enough.
And this is the reason why 77%--
sorry-- only 25%.
25% of the people
right now on Earth
are dealing with depression.
This is the reason.
Because people
don't understand why
they should invest
in their mind.
Why they should practice
on a daily basis.
This is the reason.
This is the reason why
people are sad, why people
can't come out of the bed.
And think about it.
Everyone loses.
The society loses, you
lose, your company loses.
Everyone loses.
So being positive
or having the best
mindset that will take
you one step forward
is not just for you.
It's just for everyone.
It's for your family.
It's for your kids.
It's for yourself.
It's for the society.
It's for everyone.
This is the reason
it's so important.
You can get out of the room and
say, OK, it was a nice talk,
but I don't want to practice.
Because it brings you, it
leads you to mediocrity.
And you are not part of the
world that live mediocre lives.
You're Googlers, right?
OK.
So thinking all the
time negative thoughts
destroys everything.
Destroys our life.
And as I told you before,
destroys the society,
destroys everything.
And means that you say to
yourself, I'm not smart enough.
He's smarter.
He's better.
Who think to himself this
kind of thought today?
He's smarter, she's prettier,
I'm not good enough.
Everything about I'm
a loser, I'm a loser.
Everyone is better than me.
This kind of thought destroys
your self-confidence.
Destroys the person that you
can be, destroys your potential.
And if you want to change
it, all you need to do
is practice because this is
your life and it's your show
and you are the master of this
life and you need to practice.
Not need you, I offer you to
practice and to help yourself
become a better version.
Because you need to live
with yourself everyday.
No one else, just you.
I would like to tell you
a bit about my story.
When I delivered my
third son [INAUDIBLE],,
I decided to deliver
him without painkillers.
Now, for the guys in the
room, I would like to explain.
Think about the root canal
treatment without pain killer
ten times.
This is labor.
OK?
So this is a very
painful situation.
And I don't know
if it was mistake
or not to do it
without painkiller,
but this wasn't my goal.
The goal was to have the
delivery without painkiller
and not to suffer.
I didn't want to suffer.
I wanted the pain
pass through me
and I finish this
labor like nothing.
This was the goal.
Next time that I go
in to have a baby,
I'm not going to do it anymore.
This is one time.
But I wanted to
enjoy the experience.
So I delivered my
third [INAUDIBLE],,
during this delivery,
it was very painful.
Of course, I forgot everything.
I didn't remember who I am.
I just wanted these drugs.
But then my husband reminded
me that I practiced.
Over nine months, I practiced
this minute, this hours.
I practiced for nine months.
And I had a meditation
trick for myself
with my voice that I told
myself that I can handle it.
And this is pain and it
goes away and I don't have--
I don't need to worry.
It will leave me.
Yes, it's painful,
yet I can handle it.
And I just put it on
my ear and lie down
and some magic happened.
I just take a big
breath in, listen
to myself in very powerful
voice, while I trained
myself for nine months.
And then the pain left
me and I stayed alive
and just take a big breath
when the contraction arrived
and let the pain leave me again.
And then I understood it.
In a minute, I
understood it, how
to control the
pain, how to let go.
I understood so many
important things,
and that's what I want
to share with you.
So when I came home with my
baby, I had three victories.
One, I had my adorable,
incredible, amazing, wonderful
boy.
The second one, I felt
that I'm a winner,
that I have a power over my
life and I can do anything.
And the third one,
that my app, ThinkUp,
which we will talk
about in a few minutes,
released for the first
time to app store.
And the version was
approved and everything
and had her own life.
We started with this
app and we heard
so many successful stories.
Again, I'm not trying to--
I don't want you to
download the app.
If you want to download the
app and you think that this
is the best tool, you do it.
If you can stand in front of
a mirror and say, I'm good,
every day, I'm getting better
and better, it's fine with me.
It's not selling the app.
But I would like to
tell you my experience.
We heard so many
successful stories
about people with
depression that
released the symptoms of
depression using the app.
And we have people that
relieve the symptom of grief.
We had even one lady
that talked to us
about preparing her body to
surgery, to cancer surgery,
with our app.
But the most powerful
one for me was an infant
arrived to Stanford Hospital to
have some surgery in his heart.
And during the
preparation, all his body
got [INAUDIBLE] with a virus
and the situation was very bad.
He's two years old,
this kid, Jonathan.
And the parents were
devastated and they are so sad
and they didn't know what to do
and I really tried to help them
and I didn't know why.
Anyway, I arrived
to the hospital.
They're a part of the
Israeli community,
so we know everything
about everyone.
And I arrived to the hospital
and I told them, listen,
instead of listening all
the day of your complaints,
if the baby could listen
to his mother encourage him
on a daily basis while
he was in the hospital,
while he was hospitalized, he
can listen to her, my dear son,
I know that it's a very, very
difficult moment for you.
But I really want to be
with you and it's important
for me to hug you
and to kiss you
and daddy wants to pick you
up, blah blah blah blah blah.
And after one week
of listening to--
of making him listen to
this audio, he just woke up.
So I don't know if this is the
reason, but one thing I know
that all that common traits,
all the in common of all
those stories is this app.
We can take a big breath in.
Take your hands down.
We can do a little meditation.
Take a big breath in and out.
Close your eyes,
release your hands.
[GENTLE ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
PLAYING]
Close it.
We didn't come to
waste your time.
We came here to
improve your ways.
So take a big breath in and out.
OK.
Every day, I move
one step forward.
I believe in myself.
I have the ability to succeed.
Life is good.
I'm grateful.
Take a big breath in and out.
I know who I am and it is good.
Every day, in every way, I'm
getting better and better.
I feel a deep sense
of satisfaction.
I can accomplish anything
I set my mind to.
I was born to be successful.
I love myself, respect myself,
and accept myself exactly
as I am.
Just take a big
breath in and release.
[MUSIC STOPS]
Think what can
become of you if you
train your brain over and
over again based on research.
This is so easy to do.
It will empower you
that inside your head,
you have the
thought all the time
that you are born
to be successful.
You are born, you deserve
all the good in your life.
If you train yourself to be
grateful on a daily basis,
you increase your
self-confidence,
you increase the level of
satisfaction from life,
and it will make you a better
employee, better husband
or wife.
It will help you to do
anything in your life.
It encourages you to be
a better person, a better
version of you.
Now, if you use your voice,
your brain understands it more.
And if you choose your music, it
releases dopamine in your body
and it engages your
emotional part of the brain.
So basically, what
I'm saying here,
this is kind of a personalized
meditation only for you
that will be good only for you.
Let's talk about research.
So there are
thousands of thousands
of researches talking
about positive psychology
and the body and your
success and your finance.
And there is a lot.
I will say only a few.
So the first one that you,
of course, can read about
is about positive thinkers
cope better with stress
and have a better performance.
And I'm not going to say--
I'm not going to explain
every one of them,
but the one that interested me,
it's about your immune system.
So researchers show
that activation
in the brain area associated
with negative emotion
leads to--
oh, I forgot the word.
Leads to a weaker--
to a weaker immune system.
Bluh, I forgot.
Sorry.
So it means that if you
have negative thoughts,
your immune system is weaker.
So they took two groups
of people, very optimistic
and very pessimistic people.
Both of the group
give nasal spray
and what they showed
in this research
was that the group
with positive emotion
had two times less
likely to get the flu.
Means that if you train
yourself for positivity,
you will be healthier.
And flu is just something
small, but everyone
want to be healthier, right?
So this is very
interesting research.
But again, there are a lot,
a lot, a lot of researches.
The one that interests me--
of course, you hear about it,
I know that you had a lecture
on it and talks on it in Google.
And this is the neuroplasticity.
Neuroplasticity is a field
that proves, with no doubt,
that the brain can
change his wire
and his structure when
you think positive.
Means that if you train
yourself on a daily basis--
because repetition is
the key for success.
Think about it.
Every day, you come to
work, you work for 9, 10--
I don't know, 11, afraid
to think about it.
But you work for, let's
say, 10 hours, 9 hours,
yeah, and you train
yourself over and over
again to write code, to do
the thing that you do all day.
But to train your brain
to think positive,
you don't even have time for it.
So I offer you--
neuroplasticity is a
very interesting field.
But there is another
research, very interesting,
about poverty versus wealthy.
And this man, Tom
Corley, this is
the guy that did the research.
He talked to 233 people that
are very wealthy versus 128
people that are very poor.
And he shows that all
the people, that wealthy
have 16 things in common,
16 thoughts in common.
I will talk only
about five, but there
are 16 in common traits
to all the people
that have a lot, a
lot, a lot of money.
So the first one, never give up.
Doesn't matter what happened.
Never give up.
Focus your mind on a goal.
Visualize it, move
one step forward,
move the other step forward.
Never give up.
It doesn't work, go
to this direction.
It doesn't work, just
move to this direction.
As much as you keep doing
and moving and never give up,
this is the key.
The second, avoid toxic people.
Very rich people,
very wealthy people
understand that people
that don't believe in them,
that don't encourage them, don't
move them one step forward,
are not part of their
relation friends.
And think about it.
Our peers are so important.
All what they are talking
about stay inside our head, so
think about it.
Choose the right friends
that believe in you.
Now, I'm not saying just
to throw away friends, no.
I just say, put your focus on
the people that uplift you.
The third one, find
your limiting beliefs.
What it means?
It's not so difficult
as you think.
It's easier than you think.
Every one of us has
limiting beliefs.
Like money don't grow on trees.
This is limiting beliefs.
Like I can't do it.
Like if you're rich,
you are miserable.
You will never be rich if you
think that if you are rich,
you will be miserable.
Never.
It doesn't matter how
much money you will have,
doesn't matter how much
luck you will have.
You will never be
rich if you think so.
So I offer you to find
your limiting beliefs.
In our workshop,
we work exactly how
to find those limiting beliefs.
What are the steps that we
need to do in order to know
what are your limiting beliefs?
You, every one of you,
has limiting beliefs.
We can help you to find them.
And then, when you find
them, you can use ThinkUp.
This is our solution
to change them.
So our baseline is
we know how to solve
these limiting beliefs.
This, we know, because
we have the tools.
But first, you
need to find them.
And to find them, what
are your limiting beliefs,
we offer our workshop.
But you can do it with a coach,
you can do it with a friend,
you can do it with yourself.
You can do it in any way.
Eliminate bad luck
from your vocabulary.
Life is not luck.
It doesn't just happen to you.
It doesn't happen to you.
You created your life,
therefore luck is not--
it can be one time
luck, two time luck,
but it's not on a daily basis.
Life is life.
Ups, downs, that's it.
And know your main
purpose is one.
Purpose is so important.
You can miss your life doing
something that you don't love.
You can miss so precious time.
So no what is your purpose
and go through this purpose
and do the thing
that you are unique.
OK.
So a bit about our solutions.
So let's summarize
what we say until now.
Two things.
The first one, if you
want to be successful,
you need to condition
your mind for success.
You need to understand how
successful people think.
You need to
understand what to do
and it's much easier
than you think.
Every thought you have, whether
it's conscious or subconscious
thoughts, determine
your self-talk.
Negative self-talk can
sabotage and undermine
any effort in your life.
So you need to control
your thought because this
is your show again.
And because this is your
show and because you
are the main character
of this show,
try to delete completely
your negative thoughts
and replace them with
positive thought.
And the third one is that we
have the solution for changing
our self-talk to positive.
So in our app, what you do
is you choose the new mindset
that you want to adopt.
Record it in your own
voice because your voice
is so important.
Your brain understands
your voice the most.
It is personalized to you
and just you and no one
can use it because it's yours.
You add your favorite
music because music, again,
engages your emotional part of
the brain, which is necessary.
And you listen to it again and
again when you go to sleep.
Now, why you go to sleep?
First, you don't waste time.
The most precious thing
that you have right
now is the time, right?
So if you don't have time
for it, do it when you sleep.
You can do it when
you go out with a dog.
you fold laundry.
You can do it when
you clean the house.
It really doesn't matter.
You can do it when you
work, in the background.
And when your conscious mind
is not focused on this talk,
your subconscious
mind can start--
he listens to it.
And if you put it again
and again and again--
while you work, with headphones,
no one listens to it--
your mindset will change.
So it's something
that you can do.
All you need to do is
you need to understand
that that's what you want.
This is the plan,
this one step forward,
this is day after day after day
after day until you achieve it.
And not to achieve
it is not an option.
One thing that I
can tell you that--
the bad thing of--
if we need to talk about
the difficulties right now,
is only 3% of the
people in the world
can practice ThinkUp
on a daily basis.
[PERSON SNEEZES]
Bless you.
Only 3%, but you,
the one that's here
and the one that listens to
us, you are part of the 3%.
It's not easy, you know?
Like it's not easy to do diet.
It's not easy, even though we
just press on the Play button.
That's it.
You don't need to do anything.
Even though it would
be very difficult.
But you need to commit
that you're going to do it.
And if you decide that
you're going to do it,
you're going to win it.
And this is the whole story.
You just need to commit
because we have a lot--
you can read about it.
As much as you read,
you understand how much
positivity is important to
your body, to your life,
to your children.
How many of you
have children here?
OK.
Most of you.
So part of us don't really
want to be good for ourself.
But for our kids,
it's different story.
When we see that they
do something negative,
it hurts us.
We really want for our child.
So think about your child.
What will become of you if
you will be more positive?
What will become of them?
This is a good why because
sometimes, for yourself, you
don't do, good, for others,
it's something else.
So if you decide to commit
that you want it and,
again, you can use
the free version.
It's not downloading, it's
not making money here.
It's the purpose.
And the purpose is
to spread positivity
and this is my life mission.
And you are going to do it.
You're going to do it
for my life mission.
I'm just kidding, of course.
My kids train themself
on a daily basis
and this is very,
very important to me.
And what happened is that
they put it to themselves
when they go to sleep,
just press the Play button
and that's it.
No more.
And right now, when I go out
with a phone, one of them
used my phone because
he doesn't have.
And when I go out, he put
a lot of notes in the house
that I will remember to
put ThinkUp near his bed.
And I want you to
hear how it sounds.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[GENTLE GUITAR MUSIC PLAYING]
- I believe in myself and I
have the ability to succeed.
I love myself and I
have all I need it life.
IRIT WALD: Can you hear it?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Every day, in every way,
I'm getting better and better.
I'm a good brother and I
have a great relationship
with my siblings.
[END PLAYBACK]
IRIT WALD: This one,
I asked him to put.
I have a great relationship with
my siblings, I am a great son,
I do what my mom tells me to do.
So it's easier, it's easier.
But the thing is
they really like it.
And we are better parents
and they're better kids.
They are more confident.
They are more, you know--
some day, I was mad at him
and he told me, I do my best
and that is enough.
Just he told me this, I'm doing
my best and this is enough.
So we delete this sentence.
But anyway, it becomes
part of your thoughts.
When practicing it, it
becomes part of your thought,
and you walk all your
day with yourself,
with this thought that I'm
grateful exactly as I am.
I recommend you to
download the app
and to try it for one month.
And I can tell you
from my experience
that after one month, I
felt much more happier.
I just smile all the
time after one month.
After two months, I felt a
deep sense of satisfaction.
And after two and a
half years, I just
feel that I can do anything.
So try it for one month.
It will change your mood.
It will change everything
inside your body.
And again, you don't
need to try ThinkUp.
You can stand in front of
the mirror for one month.
Stand in front of the mirror
and say, I love myself.
I can do anything
I set my mind to.
I choose to think positive
thoughts on daily basis.
This is the core to succeed in
anything that you want in life.
This is the basic.
And celebrate your victories.
Now, about the page
that I gave you,
this is a reminder for you.
Put it on your table.
It's nothing about
ThinkUp, I think.
In the middle of difficulty
lies opportunity.
Think about every opportunity
you have in the way.
Don't focus human
on the difficulties.
Try to be grateful on
anything that you have.
Celebrate your victories,
like I told you,
with the small papers.
Put it in the drawer.
Every Friday, open the drawer.
Look what happens to you.
You will become happier,
much more satisfied.
And practice positivity for
10 minutes a day with any tool
that you want.
So put it on your tables and
remind you for one month.
If after one month, doing
it day after day after day,
nothing happened to you, I
would like you to write me
and I will help you
personally, every one of you.
I will help you
reach your goals.
Deal?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]